well it's a more cautious approach from
the first minister here in wales it is
what we had
expected over the last four weeks wales
has been in a very small transition
between alert level two
and alert level one what the first
minister
uh mark drakeford will confirm when he
makes the announcement formally
in the welsh parliament this afternoon
is that from saturday
wales will move to alert level one what
does that mean well
as you just mentioned there it's a big
impact for how people can meet together
indoors here in wales at the moment it's
been restricted to three households
a bubble of three households that you've
got to keep the same so from saturday
that changes
it goes back to the old rule of six here
in wales so you can meet
with up to five other people from as
many households
so that is the big change in terms of
people's lives
there are a couple of other elements
which are going to change from
saturday uh indoor organized events of
up to a thousand people
seated and 200 standard they will be
allowed also ice rinks
will be open for the first time in a
year and a half those are
really the significant changes if it
carries on to go
if that goes well and the kobe numbers
continue to fall
then we will see wales on august the 7th
move to
alert level zero this is a brand new
level which is being announced in wales
today
and it's really similar to what is
happening in england on monday
uh all premises can open so you'll see
nightclubs reopening from the 7th of
august
most restrictions will be removed in
wales they'll be replaced by what the
welsh government says is
risk assessments to be carried out by
the individual premises
no legal limits on the number of people
meeting indoors so
in a way the unlocking day whatever you
want to call it happening in england
monday
it it's going to be similar to scotland
here in wales they're going to push it
back into august
so from the 7th of august you mentioned
face coverings there as well
what is interesting is that wales we
already knew is keeping the law on
wearing face masks on public transport
and in some social care settings we knew
that was going to happen
but actually from the 7th of august when
the restrictions all lift they are
keeping the
face covering law in most public places
apart from hospitality
so my reading of that is that from the
7th of august shops will still have to
buy law
and make sure people are wearing face
masks even though the rest of the
restrictions are
all going in nightclubs are opening mark
drake for the first minister
said that we can be reasonably confident
that vaccination
has weakened the link between infections
and serious illness
but there is still a risk that this
third wave of the pandemic could cause
real harm so a more cautious approach no
big freedom day yet here
in wales um but people from saturday
night at least will be able to meet up
with more of their friends
indoors they will have to wait till
august 7th for more freedoms to be
introduced